cuando platicábamos acerca de fracciones
hablábamos de simplificar las o bien de
ponerlas en forma reducida por ejemplo
si teníamos un 3 sextos un 3 sextos
entonces el 3 y el 6 tenían un factor en
común y por tanto podríamos escribir
esto como bueno el 3 simplemente es un 3
pero el 6 lo factorizar vamos como 3 por
2 y ahora podríamos dividir el numerador
y el denominador entre 3 para cancelar
estos 3 o bien pensar esta fracción como
3 entre 3 por un medio y nos quedaba
igual a un medio porque este 3 entre 3
es un 1 para darte otro ejemplo para que
quede clarísimo a lo que me refiero por
ejemplo también si teníamos no sé 8
entre 24 8 entre 24 entonces podíamos
factorizar el denominador y nos quedaba
8 entre 3 por 24 3 por 8 perdón porque
24 3 por 8 y pensando esto como un
tercio por 8 entre 8 nos quedaba que la
fracción original era igual a un tercio
este un tercio y este un medio eran las
formas simplificadas o bien reducidas de
cada una de estas fracciones bueno
resulta que esa misma idea también se
aplica en las expresiones racionales en
las cuales el numerador y el denominador
ya no son números concretos sino que son
expresiones que pueden tener variables
déjame poner un ejemplo para mostrarte a
qué me refiero digamos que tenemos no sé
la expresión racional 9 x + 3 dividida
dividida entre 12 x 12 x + 4 vale
entonces cuál va a ser la idea vamos a
factorizar el numerador y el denominador
para ver qué nos queda en el numerador
podemos factorizar un 3 pues ambos suman
dos son múltiplos de 3 nos quedaría 3 x
3 x + + 1 y en el denominador
ambos son múltiplos de 4 nos quedaría 4
por 12 entre 4 es 3 esa x queda ahí y 4
entre 4 es 1
entonces observa una vez más el
numerador y el denominador tienen cosas
en común ahora no es un número sino que
es una expresión que tiene la variable x
pero aplica exactamente la misma idea
que aquí arriba podemos cancelar esta
expresión y esta expresión y por lo
tanto esto nos quedaría igual a tres
cuartos salvo un detallito que ahorita
te voy a decir nada más déjame darte un
ejemplo un ejemplo aquí abajo un ejemplo
adicional para seguir con estas ideas
imagínate que ahora nos piden
simplificar x al cuadrado menos nueve
dividido entre vamos a ponerle 5 x 5 x
más 15 más 5 x + 15 bueno otra vez vamos
a factorizar el numerador y el
denominador el numerador es una
diferencia de cuadrados y por lo tanto
se puede factorizar como como x menos 3
x x + 3 x + 3 y en el denominador
ambos son múltiplos de 5 sacamos el 5 y
nos queda 5 x
+ 15 en 35 que es 3 vale entonces
observa arriba y abajo tenemos un x 3 de
forma que podemos cancelar los pero
tenemos que ser cuidadosos este es el
detallito que te decía osea esta
expresión si es igual a x menos 3 en 3 x
menos 3 entre 5 entre 5 pero siempre y
cuando pidamos una condición adicional
por qué pues porque hay que ser
cuidadosos que al cancelar este x + 3 y
este x + 3 no estemos cancelando un cero
porque porque si x más 3 fuera 0
entonces estaríamos dividiendo entre 0
entonces esta expresión que es la misma
que ésta no estaría definida es decir es
decir esta expresión es igual a x menos
3 entre 5 siempre y cuando siempre y
cuando pidamos la condición adicional de
que x sea distinto a menos tres a menos
tres para que el denominador no se anule
no se vuelva a cero entonces eso es algo
muy importante sale esta expresión
y esta expresión por sí mismas no son
equivalentes porque esta la podemos
evaluar en menos tres y ésta no no está
definida pero esta expresión con todo
esto con todo y la condición x distinto
a menos 3 si son equivalentes entonces
ahí sí son equivalentes vale bueno
entonces vamos hacia arriba para para
volver a ver cuál sería la condición que
tenemos que cuidar
aquí lo que cancelamos fue un 3 x + 1
arriba y abajo entonces hay que cuidar
que eso no sea cero es decir tenemos que
pedir que que x sea distinto de de menos
un tercio menos un tercio vale no hay
que irse con la cinta o sea si
quisiéramos graficar ye igual a 9 x + 3
entre 12 x 4 podríamos irnos con la
tentación de simplificar y decir que la
gráfica es exactamente la misma que la
gráfica de g
igual a 13 a tres cuartos pero no la
gráfica de ye igual a tres cuartos es
una línea horizontal
tres cuartos a la altura tres cuartos
está definida en todos los reales pero
esta expresión tiene problemas con x
igual a menos un tercio porque en el
denominador tenemos un cero vale
entonces está si es equivalente a esta
siempre y cuando pidamos la condición
adicional x distinto de menos un tercio
menos un tercio bueno creo que ahí no se
ve muy bien pero aquí está escrita sale
es esto de acá bueno vamos a hacer otro
problema para seguir pues agarrando
estas ideas este va a ser un poquito más
complicado y dice lo siguiente dice
simplifica x al cuadrado x al cuadrado
más 6 x 5 6 x + 5 está más interesante
está más padre entre x al cuadrado menos
x
no lo va a poner menos 2 - x2 muy bien
entonces misma idea actualizamos
numerador y denominador y cancelamos
siendo cuidadosos vamos a factorizar el
numerador cómo le hacemos para
factorizar una expresión cuadrática
donde el primer coeficiente es 1 pues
tenemos que buscar dos números que
sumados nos den 6 y que multiplicados
nos den 5 está fácil son 5 y 1 entonces
se factorizar como x + 5 x x + 1 x + 1
vamos con el denominador otra vez vamos
a factorizar lo y ahora hay que buscar
dos números que sumados nos den menos 1
y multiplicados nos den menos 2 entonces
sería x son como dos y uno solo que el
más grande debe ser negativo para que
aquí nos quede menos entonces sería x 2
x x más 1 bueno puedes verificar
haciendo la multiplicación para ver que
en efecto queda esto de acá pero observa
una vez más nos queda x + 1 en el
numerador y en el denominador entonces
podemos cancelar lo podemos cancelarlo y
esto
y es igual a déjame quitar el paréntesis
a x 5 dividido entre x2 pero cuidando
que nunca dividamos entre 0 es decir que
esta cancelación se puede hacer y para
eso necesitamos que x sea distinto de
menos 1 vale entonces otra vez esta
expresión y esta expresión son
equivalentes siempre y cuando pidamos x
distinto de menos 1 si no pedimos eso y
nos quedamos nada más con esta de acá
pues no son equivalentes porque ésta se
puede evaluar en menos 1 y esta de acá
no se puede evaluar en menos 1 vale
entonces tenemos que pedir las dos para
que sean equivalentes muy bien bueno
vamos a hacer un último que está un
poquito más complicado porque ahora la
factorización no queda tan fácil y dice
lo siguiente lo voy a hacer en color lo
voy a hacer con dos colores para que sea
más claro lo que estamos haciendo lo voy
a hacer con este naranja brillante
entonces vamos a ponerle 3 x cuadrada 3
x cuadrada más 3 x
-18 y eso lo vamos a dividir entre con
este color rosa vamos a ponerle aquí
abajo 2 x al cuadrado 2 x al cuadrado
más 5 x menos 3 creo que es como morado
bueno no importa vale entonces tenemos
que factorizar el numerador y el
denominador ahora es un poquito más
complicado porque el coeficiente
principal no es 1 pero podemos
factorizar por agrupamiento vamos a
hacer eso aquí a la derecha
entonces tenemos que factorizar 3 lo voy
a hacer un poco más acá 3x al cuadrado
más 3x menos 18 y la idea de factorizar
por agrupamiento es que ahora tenemos
que buscar números a ive tales que a más
b sea el coeficiente lineal o sea 3 y
que a por b sea el producto de los
coeficientes de los extremos y 3 x menos
18 es menos 54 a ver nuestro nuestro tan
fácil pero pero a ver este de aquí es
múltiplo de 9 y está la diferencia 3
creo que 9 y 6 funcionan y ya nada más
hay que elegir los signos y igual a 9 y
b igual a menos 6 igual a menos 6
funcionan sí 96 es 39 por menos 6 654
muy bien entonces la idea de factorizar
por agrupamiento es que ahora este 3x lo
separamos en dos sumandos en un 9 x y un
menos 6 x entonces déjame poner el 9 x
con el 3x cuadrada porque tienen el
mismo signo entonces nos quedaría 3 x 4
+ 9 x menos 6 x 18 digo pude haber
puesto el 6 acá porque también es
múltiplo de 3 pero como los dos son
múltiplos de 3 me voy a guiar por el
signo vale bueno entonces este 9 x con
este menú 6x estos 2 de acá son
exactamente lo mismo que este 3x así que
no he cambiado nada pero ahora tenemos
la ventaja de que aquí podemos
factorizar un 3x podemos ponerlo como 3x
x x + 3 sale hacer la multiplicación y
queda esto y aquí podemos factorizar un
6 pues ambos son múltiplos de 6 menos 6
por x más 3 18 entre 6 estrés y menos
entre menos es más
ok mirad esto está padre funciona
nuestra factorización por agrupamiento
aquí queda x + 3 y aquí también entonces
distribuyendo esto nos quedaría 3x menos
6 x x
muy bien entonces esa es la
factorización del numerador deja la
copia aquí arriba esto es igual
a 3 x menos 63 x menos 6 x x + 3 con un
poco de suerte en el denominador también
vamos a tener algunos de estos factores
déjame factorizar lo aquí a la derecha
entonces nos quedaría bueno lo voy a
copiar 2 x cuadrada más 5 x menos 3
ahora buscamos a ivette al que la suma
sea el coeficiente lineal que acompaña a
la equis o sea 5 y que el producto sea
el producto de los de los extremos de
los coeficientes extremos 2 x menos 3 es
menos fish entonces qué números sumados
dan 5 y multiplicados dan menos 6 pues 6
y menos uno entonces igual a 6 b igual a
menos 1 funciona vale 6 menos 15 6 x
menos 1 es menos 6 separamos esto este
5x lo partimos en un 6 x y de un menos x
el 6 lo voy a poner con el 2 porque es
múltiplo de dos entonces nos quedaría 2x
al cuadrado más 6 x
- x - x menos 3 factor izamos de aquí un
2x vamos a factorizar un 2x nos queda 2x
x x + 3 y aquí voy a factorizar un menos
uno por x más 3 excelente ay quedó el x
+ 3 que también aparece acá estos son
muy buenas noticias este 2 x 1 y este
menos 1 se pueden factorizar o más bien
de distribuir 2 x menos 1 x x + 3 y
entonces la factorización del
denominador queda como 2 x menos 12 x
menos 1 x x + 3 uf muchísimo trabajo
verdad pero bueno finalmente llegamos a
nuestro resultado aquí podemos cancelar
el x + 3 con el x 3 y entonces esta
expresión es igual a 3 x menos 6 entre 2
x 1 y hay que recordar la cosa que es
bien importante que para poder hacer
esta cancelación necesitamos pedir que x
o sea distinto de menos
le tenemos que pedir que x 3 no sea 0
muy bien espero que te hayan gustado
estos problemas y que ésta pues este
vídeo de simplificar expresiones
racionales te sea de utilidad nos vemos
hasta la próxima